in one short week halo 3 is coming to PC
the mafia definitive edition has been
delayed and the developers behind
shovelknight are working on a brand new
3d game i'm persia and you've reached
your save state for tuesday july 7 along
with the start of Master Chief
collections second season halo 3 is
coming to PC on July 14th the update is
set to roll out around 10 a.m. Pacific
and 1 p.m. Eastern and will also include
an update to the battle path reward
system to allow you to choose the
rewards you won instead of earning them
at different tiers of the pass ODST and
halo 4 will be joining the collection at
a later date but if you don't want to
wait they're obviously all currently
available on Xbox one through the mcc
but if you're actually wondering more
about halo infinite well we're expected
to see more information about that
during the Xbox 20/20 stream that's
going to be on July 23rd 2k games has
announced a delay to the Mafia
definitive edition remastered shifting
its release date from August 28th to
September 25th 2k games stated
finalizing everything in time for the
August release date has become
increasingly challenging due to the
ongoing global covet 19 pandemic and the
last thing we want to do is compromise
the quality of the experience hangar 13
m2k aren't leaving us in the dark during
the delay as extended gameplay is set to
be revealed on July 22nd to hold us over
until launch and if you're really
itching for some mafia then don't forget
that the definitive edition for mafia 2
& 3 or 4 already Ellis Yacht Club games
the developers behind shovel knight have
posted some new job listings that
suggest at least one project in
production is going to be a 3d title the
listing said Yacht Club games is working
on a new 3d project and is building out
our 3d team and custom engine to
complement our existing 2d team this is
pretty significant because not only is
the developer known for the 2d retro
style games but they also have three new
2d games confirmed to be in the works
although there wasn't any other info
about the 3d game we know that shovel
knight dig shovel knight pocket dungeon
and the publishing of cipher shadow
already been confirmed looks like
there's going to be no shortage of
things to play from Yacht Club games
while their 3d titles and production and
don't forget you guys we are in the
final week of play fur all we've already
raised almost $40,000 for black lives
matter and Cova 19 relief efforts but
there are still ways for you guys to
support through to the end of the month
and here's how just go ahead and go to
storage gamespot.com
and you'll be able to get your hands on
some exclusive play from merch and all
those proceeds are going to the same
great causes we've been supporting all
summer and later this week we still have
more action to come we're doing some
coverage on Ubisoft beau-word and other
amazing things so still a lot to come
this week and still many ways for you to
support that's it for AI news this
Tuesday thank you guys so much for
tuning in you can follow me on twitter
at persia underscore XO and most
importantly make sure you reach your
next save date tomorrow with kirt I'll
see you guys next time
[Music]